ou hier soir il y avait laamouré dans le
Pr qui a regardé laamouré dans le Pr
quoi même pas Kelly qui regarde non pas
ce coupci non non et vous oui bien s
saviez qu'il fallait travailler pour
l'émission
ouais je
désoléavou j'avoue j'ai pas mais promis
la semaine prochaine je regarde sûr
comment ça se fait bah
écoutez on dirait un profit déçu
vraiment je suis dé suis désolé émission
c'est vrai que c'est ma cam normalement
tu es ouais ouais ouais ouais j'ai
regardé un film super ah ouais c'était
quoi
un film américain une prostituée qui
vend des médicaments après je l'ai vu
c'est quoi jeai vu jeai vu je vu
également ah oui ouais c'est
un non non j'ai pas vu le film je
connais pas mais je connais pas du tout
ce film en tout cas ça a l'air
sympa si qui vaut des médicaments ben
écoutez on essaiera de voir ce que c'est
euh va vous êtes catastrophique mais en
tout cas vous bossez ici on va revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé hier soir dans
l'amour et dans le prè et il y avait
Julien l'éleveur du dou le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il a vraiment aucun
filtre il est hyper cache Julien
regardez dans un instant on va recevoir
Mathieu candidat emblématique de la
saison 15 j'aime bien savoir ce qu'ils
sont devenus et ce il sera avec nous
dans un instant c'est parti quoi tu
manges jamais le gâteau si mais je le
mange je le sers
pas non mais c'est toi qui fait alors là
tu touches
bout au speed deting j'ai discuté avec
lui il m'a regardé dans les yeux j'ai eu
une demi
C feeling tues pas au courant on est
resté 3 He dans un spa avec des
Bull le soir je te disain j'ai 3h de
temps c'est super mal m non là une
pendule ti unet tu à
l'aise je pens je
suisiseieve nous
pourff maieu de la saison 15 très
sympathique mathieuah c'est tout qui me
revient làie comment ça va mon chéri ça
va très bien merci d'être là avec
plaisir tu regardes toujours ou pas ah
bah bien sûr j'étais là devant hier soir
is tu à fond bah j'aime bien quand même
tuaimes bien c'est pas alors je me
rappelle toi tu étais tu avais comment
tu avais rencontré Alexandre dans
l'aventure ouais on mis un couple
magnifique on en aille parl iou on a
réussi notre mariage mais on a aussi
réussi notre divorce al ça qu'on en
parle parce que j'ai besoin de savoir où
tu en es toi regarde à l'époque vous
nous aviez beaucoup touché regarde
fallait absolument que que je te rend
compte quoi mais je suis pas déçus bien
non pas du tout tuas un beau regard un
pe j'ai un beau regard OK
aussi mais je suis excité de le le
prendre dans ma vie de le de l'emmener
de le de le
transporter vers mes rêves vers vers
tout ce que j'ai envie de
faire je me dis bon dans 15 10 ans 15
ans quand je serai tout
frppé qu'est-ce qu'il va penser
qu'est-ce qui alors quand je lui exprime
tout ça il me regarde comme si je je
parlais chinois ça pas la tête tu t'en
fut je m'en fous complètement c'est beau
hein oua c'est vrai ouis
ouis
ouais pas
mal et cette année on t' retrouvé en duo
avec Didier la star de la saison 14
ouais on est parti on est parti quelques
jours en camping-car c'est ça ouais on a
beaucoup ri alors
euh non non aucun non non non alors sur
les réseaux cétait sur 6isplay hein
c'était une série sur 6play sur les
réseaux les gens disent bah ça y est DJ
non non
pent chose qui ou mais mais regarde mais
non regarde
mais ça sera ta chambre
des une
échelle c'esti
ça c'est un
ordinateur c'est pour choper ça non pour
choper
non tu vas pas prendre une petite valise
comme
ça met je mets
pantal mais tu sais pas nager mais c'est
pas alors Matthieu on va revenir sur
l'épisode d'hier soir de l'amour est
dans le Pr après on va en savoir un
petit peu plus sur toi c'est important
pour nous on a besoin de savoir où tu en
es c'est important alors il y avait
Jean-Paul hier le céréalier qui est
parti en vacances au Portugal avec sa
prétendante Maria sauf qu'elle elle est
pas là pour profiter elle est là pour
mettre la misère à jean-pa regarde on va
se poser 5 minutes un peu pour être au
calme 5 minutes h tu as déjà fait du
yoga ouais j'ai vu comment ça se passait
mais non la question cétait est-ce que
tu as déjà fait du yoga voilà ends je
vais prendre un peu de ça
ve c'est bien tu as dit t on veut bah je
vais doucement non tu as dit Ton veut
c'est
bien c'est bien tu as dit ton veu c'est
bien ça vient naturellement voilà c'est
bien Natur normalement ça vient Natur ça
je comprends
[Applaudissements]
pas il s'améliore mais c'est pas encore
ça il a des efforts à faire il est
encore un peu
rus ouais c'est pas mal Heon il est il
est il est rustre mais elle est trop en
attente he quand même ouais ouais c'est
ça elle est hyper en attente c'est ça
elle le reprend surt sur elle est alors
on poursuit avec Christine l'éleveuse de
chien de nouvelle Aquitaine qui n'a pas
eu le coup de cœur pour son prétendant
Alain malgré tout lui il lâche pas
laaffire mais il se prend que des vents
regardez
cher non non merci je vois que tuas un
peu de vente quand même j'avais pas vu
avec les chemises
larges non mais alors le polo dedans là
ça va pas du toutement me suis posé la
question je suis d'accord après ton
passage chez moi tu seruras t'habillé tu
fais cadeau le polo vert si tu veux
c'est mon cadeau de voilà d'amitié et
puis ben comme ça tu auras un souvenir
de moi ce bonheur là brillera dans tes
yeux pour toute la vie si tu le veux
d'accord merci Alle à notre santé santé
et à mes
chiens
c'est pas
ouf il m'a rappelé potieran il m'a
rappelé Julien Robert franchement il y
avait un bail mais le problème c'est que
la première fois qu'il est arrivé il est
arrivé en sabot en bois avec une un
vêtement de jardin ouais donc pour
draguer c'est un peu compliqué quand
même hein sabot on bois les vieux sabot
là et j'adore parce que lui il voit tout
hein tu vois tous les détails alors ce
qui a fait le plus réagir sur les
réseaux ça c'est c'est le clash c'est le
plus fort de ce qui s'est passé hier
c'est entre Justin est Patrice le couple
culte de la saison il voulais fu je sais
pas dans quel sens après 3 mois de
relation Patrice en a Mar de se faire
diriger il le dit à Justine c'était le
moment fort de la soirée il en a sa
claque
regarde par c'est compliqué pour moi tu
m'aimes encore ou
pas me pose des questions quoi je me
pose des questions j'ai l'impression qu'
veut résenter toute la maison qu'elle
veut résenter ma vie tu veux me quitter
je
pasussis je
Suu moi je sers à quoi là-dedans je sers
à quoi si tu veux tout comme avant à
rien je sers à
rien pourquoi tu m'as rencontré
alors
[Musique]
pourquoi
Patrice qui a vidé son sac hein euh pas
pas le sac de par est petit le sac de J
mais elle a vidé son elle a été
énormément critiquée sur les réseaux on
dit qu'elle est trop dirigiste qu'elle
veut tout lui imposer mais moi je la
défends parce que lui il est il est
maladroit il est pas expérimenté en
amour et elle fait tout pour que ça
réussisse elle en fait trop elle surjoue
elle est mal à droite dans les mots elle
dit à un moment c'est moi qui tiens la
baraque c'est pas joli mais le couple
c'est elle donc il faut il faut qu'il
l'écoute absolument Cyril moi j'y crois
encore à coup
alors le truc c'est que dans le montage
de ce que je sais on n'a pas montré 80 %
donc là ton jugement il est sur ces 20 %
mais il y a des choses qui ont été très
très dures
compoi de d'elle de elle a été plus dur
que ça bah oui
sur on veut savoir
nous sur la la façon qu'elle avait
d'abordé quand elle était chez elle
enfin chez chez chez
eux
[Musique]
c'est vraiment quoi quoi genre quoi elle
éta dirig à la limite d'être méchante je
sais pas si d'elle c'est de la
méchanceté en tout cas que lui a reçu
c'était de la méchanceté ouais on a on a
l'impression qu'il est au bout du
rouleau lui au bout ah mais pourquoi il
supporte plus en fait au bout et puis
vous allez voir le bilan quoi c'est
chaud ou ah ouais c'est pour ça que je
déteste cette émission en fait parce que
je sais bien que tout le monde aime
cette émission et que c'est sublime et
que ça rend les gens très très heureux
et donc en fait ma parole sert à rien
mais je trouve que làah calme-toi quand
même mais là c'est jeté en pinture des
gens qui sont extrêmement fragiles et
l'un et l'autre en fait et qui savent
pas forcément aimer qui ont pas
forcément les codes de la télé des
caméras du jugement des autres elle va
se retrouver dans un shit store
monstrueux où on va l'accabler on va
dire qu'elle est méchante lui ça va être
une victime parce qu'il est peut-être
différent et c'est pas une victime parce
qu'il est différent donc c'est
insupportable et je trouve que c'est
c'est la limite de l'émission quand elle
quand elle est comme ça je trouve que
c'est du voyurisme et moi ça me choque
voilà et pour toutes les émissions c'est
comme ça moi je dirais que c'est un peu
comme ça pour toutes les émissions hein
quand même
hein est dans le regard de celui qui qui
regarde l'émission si tu as envie d'être
de de regarder l'émission avec
condescendance et être méchant et et
avoir pas d'empathie pour eux bah c'est
pasable pour toutes les émissions si en
revanche tu la regardes avec
bienveillance et que tuas et que tu as
de l'empathie pour l'un et l'autre c'est
une très jolie émission enfin moi c'est
comme ça je alors toi tu es très très tu
as beaucoupumanité moi qui suis très
condescendante je remarque que à chaque
fois qu'on monte cette émission quand
même beaucoup de gens se marrent tu vois
et donc il y a un truc quand même qui
est un tout petit peu dég aussi où on
met ses gens moi j'adore les
agriculteurs je les trouve tous
extrêmement touchants mais je trouve que
le programme les utilise voilà c'est
tout et ça me PLA pas je vrais revenir
sur ce que disait Mathieu parce que
quand vous dites tu as pas vu qu' tuas
pas vu ce qu'ils ont coupé quoi quand
Mathieu dit on a vu 20 % il y a 80 % a
dit tu as pas vu quoi parce que just tu
nas pas vu ce qu'ils ont coupé c'est ce
qu'on a dit à ma
[Rires]
circoncision voiture maie comme vous
avez l'air d'avoir des infos pourquoi
parce c'était trop violent ils ont Gou
ouais oui il y a eu des pris il y a eu
de grossse prise de conscience de la de
la production ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais qui
se c'est c'est c'est là ça pe pour les
protéger au maximum vraiment ouais ou
ouais ça dait dangereux bah ils avaient
peur de de de du retour sur image quoi
que qu'est-ce qu'ils allit faire après
on peut on peut parler de suicide après
si s'il arrive quelque chose comme ça
c'est donc il y a eu l'intervention de
il y a eu enfin ou oui ah oui oui oui ah
c'est ouf toi tu en es où toi mat parce
que toi toi tu t'étais marié ouais je
m'étais marié et puisé direct et 2 ans
après ah ouais quand même ou ouais mais
on a réussi notre divorce qu'est-ce qu'
a eu qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu alors
pourquoi ça divorcé bah un jour il est
parti en vacances jamais revenu quoi
c'est par
c'est un motif ou c'est normal il est
parti non mais il est parti une semaine
en vacances et puis il est chaé revenu
quoi quoi quo quoi attendsssend fou ça
il te dit un jour je pars en vacances et
tu l'as plus jamais revu le gars ben je
l'ai revu quelques mois après après
quand il est venu récupérer ses affaires
c'était ton mari oui et le gars il a
disparu ouis il était où en vacances à
daville àville attention a beaucoup de
meufs là-bas et de mecs il a de tout là
mais il y avait aucun signe c'està dire
il est parti il il y a eu un moment
pendant un mois un mois et demi c'était
un peu il a trouvé il a trouvé quelqu'un
à Doville ou quoi non il est parti avec
quelqu' parti ave quelqu' parti
quelqu'un ouais on parle pas de ton
expérience perso s'il te plaî merci non
mais c'est bon il est parti avec
quelqu'un je pense pas la vie lui
correspondait plus enfin bon bref c'est
c'est c'est passé maintenant on s'entend
super bien on s'est eu encore il y a 3
jours au télphone dit quoi il t'a dit
quoi euh bah la vie lui convenait plus
que la vie lui convenait plus et
euh et voilà tu tu sentais que ça allait
partir en cacahuète pas du tout non
genre tout allait bien ah bah ouais ça a
été un choc alors ah [__] quoi
vraiment et genre surtout que je l'ai
appris 3 semaines après parce que il
revenait pas ouais et c'est ma meilleure
notre meilleure amie commune qui
m'aenvoie un texto pour me dire mais
matthu il reviendra pas ah ouais j'étais
dans le train ah c'est pas vrai ah ouais
c'est un truc de ouf de ouf et il t' dit
il t'a dit quoi il t'a dit j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un non il m'a dit c'est la vie ne
me convient plus alors quand tu aimes
quelqu'un tu le retiens pas he mais tu
es sûr qu'il a il a quelqu'un je pense
il a pas parti à Doville manger des
glaces chez Martin lomber non mais je te
le dis je connais je su toujours posé la
question mais j'ai pas le j'ai pas le
vous en avez jamais reparlé il pas été
au Minig non puis j'ai plus j'ai pas
envie d'en reparler j'ai pardonné je je
suis passé à autre chose ouis c'est quoi
vraiment toi tu as pas demandé
d'explication toi ça sert à quoi ah bah
je sais pas quand même he respect bah
moi euh ma elle part du jour au
lendemain elle me dit je par j'ai j'ai
demandé j'ai écouté ces explications
après est-ce que j'ai tout cru ouais
voilà j'ai pas cherché à tu as pas voulu
le retenir
non alors il y a un truc c'est par amour
quand on aime quelqu'un et qu'il veut
partir faut le laisser partir exactement
exactement et ça c'est ça c'est la plus
belle preuve d'hamour que je lui ai fait
d'ailleurs il me le dit aujourd'hui hein
ah B il était bien content de se barrer
non je
rigole
je te
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remercie non je l'ai pas vu arriver
ça mais mais moi j'adore les histoires
tu sais moi j'adore les histoires de
couple donc c'est fou donc là tu le vois
non parce que je reprends toutes mes
débuts donc il te dit un jour je vais
partir à Doville ou il doit partir une
semaine ouais en
vacancesent de semaines 3 semaines il
revient pas non et ta meilleure copine
te dit il viendra plus ouais bon écoute
et tu en est où là tu as un ah non non
ou là tuas un nouveau BA ou pas ah non
non ah ouais foutez-moi la
paix je dire si un jour j'ai un mec ça
sera la serie sur le gâteau mais alors
la SER fais gaffe si c'est ma vie
vérifie bien qu'il en a
deux parce que sinon c'est un MonChéri
fais gaffe non non non non mais non non
quoi quoi tu as pas de mec depuis
combien de temps ben j'ai une petite
relation cet été mais ça c'est terminé
et puis pourquoi tu étais où cetété ben
j'ai j'ai loué un camping-car j'ai fait
le tour de France ah tu as trouvé
comment tu as connu la personne
par hasard pas comme ça dans le bah une
petite un peu un peu tinder là tu tu
passes dans un petit village gling gling
ça sonne tu regardes tu fais oh pas mal
ou ou oui pas mal ce campingar
euh
donc juste cette petite expérience cet
été mais rien de rien de transcendant ça
fait combien donc là fait fait là tu es
plus en coup depuis combien de temps et
ben ça fait un an et de Demi ah ouais tu
as été content quand même de faire
l'aventure ou pas Laam dans ah bah bien
sûr vraiment ouais ouais et le taf ça va
ou pas bah le taf ça va bah là j'ai
quand on s'est qui séparé en fait il est
parti un mois avant que on commence
notre GPA parce qu'on devait faire une
GPA voilà ouais et je l'ai continué seul
du coup ouais donc on est à 10 semaines
de grossesse là non magnifique ouais un
papa solo on papa solo donc mais je suis
très content de le faire seul parce que
au moins jevec Bruno Solo
ah possible ça on peut pas être
tranquille papa solo papa sol c'est très
bien papa solo parce que tu t'engueules
pas pour les prénom tu te regules pas
pour l'éducation voilà parfait parfait
donc au printemps ça sera voilà premps
tuas le ouais trop bien sera papa la
personne serait pas part voilà et ça n'a
plus posé de problème parce qu'à
l'époque vous l'avez demandé quand vous
étiez deux ouais non ça a pas posé de
problème et puis puis puis ça se passe
très bien c'est Bernard Montiel de
l'agence à
capoucou l' pas reconnu
gars c'est le gars capouco bah oui
j'avais une question euh si demain
l'amour est dans le prê faisait une
version allst par exemple est-ce que tu
tu la ferais je suis pas ouf je suis pas
sûr pas si peut-être qu'ave peut-être
avec une nouvelle présentation un
nouveau gars je suis pas sûr non
peut-être tu vois là là tu vois je on a
fait le la vie d'après parce que c'était
un nouveau concept on est parti en
camping-car on a
rigolé c'était pas mal non là je suis
plutôt là je suis en train de de
coécrire une pièce de théâtre ah ouais
avec Guillaume Mélan je sais pas gu bien
sûr voilà qui alors alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est celui qui avait
écrit eu pour amandalire paniic au
ministère il est prés coprésident de
d'urgence homophobie et on c'est une
comédie de boulevard c'est l'histoire de
d'un couple de garçons je vais jouer
dedans en plus alors c'est la
catastrophe ah ouais pant qu'on écrivait
il me disait mais en fait c'est toi qui
va jouer dedans j'ai fait pardon voilà
et avec leurs deux mères qui vont faire
une GPA donc tu auras ma mère qui est un
peu WWE ma vraie mère qu'est-ce que tu
vas te faire chier avec un gamin pendant
48 ans je me suis fait chier avec le
mien ais voilà et puis tu as l'autre ma
belle-mère qui plutôt cul serré tu vois
comme ça et qui supporte pas la GP
comprends pas pourquoi on va faire la
GPR pas mal bah écoute voir tu viendras
faire la promo ici avec plaisir très
bien donc là pour l'instant et pour
l'instant tu es bien tu es célibataire
ouais ouais ou ouais au boulot très bien
tu es tranquille tu veux pas qu'on te
fasse chier quoi surtout pas je
comprends écoute je comprends je
comprends moi je vais pas te dire voilà
donc sinon voilà tu as pas trouvé
l'amour en fait là il y en a très peu
qui reste ensemble et ben il y en a
quand même il y en a quand même bah tu
sais c'est comme dans la vie de tous les
jours hein tu as deux couples sur trois
qui divorcent et puis coup sur trois qui
divorc bah dans toute leur vie ouais
hein c'est beaucoup nonou sur
de un sur de qui divorce ouais ah ouais
et Gill Verdes c'est TR sur
qu non non mais c'est vrai non non mais
je te le dis non mais bon voilà en tout
cas [__] tu t'es marié quand même
ouais c'est ouf mais c'est fini hein je
m marierai plus ah ouais ça a changé non
non non c'est beau arrête si tu es
amoureux là
quoi mais toi tu t'es marié après une
émission a c'est pas pareil ouais mais
c'est un beau mariage hein ouais bah oui
Dieu bénisse euh non mais non mais c'est
vrai tu as fait tu as fait ça juste pour
la fête ou non non non non je tu étais
vraiment amoureux ou pas ah ouais de ouf
ouais quoi quand il est parti tu étais
au bout de ta vie ou pas léger léger
léger mais je te sensà je te sens
complètement ah ben je suis détaché
maintenant c'est bon ouais ça y est mais
c'était ouais j'étais très amoureux mais
il était beau quand même hein et s'il
revient demain non fini
non la bague fou le mec euh la bague
elle est chez moi posé sinon j'ai une
bague chez Fatou he si tu veux non non
il il il a reprise cy parce que si
demain il y a du succès avec la pièce de
théâtre reviens ah non non non non non
non non non non c'est terminé non non
non non non non non ferme laissez-moi
tranquille je vais avoir mon gosse j'ai
mes chiens je suis très bien tu as
raison bah tu veux que je te dise allez
moi je suis content pour toi et tu
reviens nous voir avec plaisir avec
plaisir on adore on l'adore on l'adore
franchement on t'a kiffé de ouf tu
reviens dans un instant on va revenir t
les T surt les débats du jour là dans un
instant Gilles donc là ça va être à toi
comme
d'habitude
[Musique]
suite